podcasts we got h-town's finest in here
Marcus clay
you'll check out his new project uh
that's out right now uh the mecca he's
got new music coming he's going to be
doing dreamville Fest in April you might
have just saw him at rolling loud this
past weekend in LA and we're gonna have
him rap because that's what he does
maybe do this is 11 years old let's do
it let's go
shout out Sean
come right in yo
[Music]
foreign
I'm a God amongst pigsness I'm a
dignitary born with a King Tut Essence
deep in the South where [__] keep
weeding they mouth and argue who rims
bigger sipping some [__] out of baby
bottle that kill [__] it's just like
hoe said we still [__] but I'm half
human in Wolverine I heal quicker I
never speak on what I did unless they
act like they forgot about it broken
reminders never shot nobody my trust has
ran as courses I added up to the Statue
of Liberty with these leeches and
backstabbing vultures I reverse the
adversity and it certainly worked for me
while I developed the strength of a
Hercules [__] they said I spit that
murder in the first degree [__] but I
ain't go to college I ain't got degrees
[__] blessed by the finest look up a
definition of a diamond in the roof
you'll find my image right beside it
disappear and get your paper right I
promise you ain't missing [__] the
internet is only a figment don't give in
to it I was an innocent child in the
middle of trial from innocent smiles to
quickly in misery these Silhouettes from
Satan with visit me until I made the
decision to straighten the trickery is
you feeling me I was a star before I
knew I could shine watching my Sun Ray
sneak through the blinds everything was
designed it was written like the nine
six nines Vivid Street Dreams reflecting
through my slick mind okay first things
first [__] with who [__] with you
unreciprocated energy is something of an
enemy in this moment in time in the 21st
century I've shown less empathy grown
more sensibly I know how it feel to be
overlooked and unappreciated the rise of
my life is deeply awaited [__]
Marcus clay bruh that was quick and that
was a one take ladies and gentlemen
that's that's a real professional right
there that's a real rapper guys he does
this
it's in him it ain't on him man right
let's appreciate y'all for having me hey
I know you just watched the new
freestyle guess what we're dropping them
every week sometimes more than once a
week Jesus we've been dropping a lot
lately uh shout out to LRG don't forget
go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off at checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week